illegal
aliens who you know in the words of even
a liberal Democrat mayor Eric Adams
illegal
aliens uh and the migrant crisis they've
caused could destroy New York City well
now some New Yorkers not just
politicians on the ground New Yorkers
are pushing back because illegal aliens
are getting free Thanksgiving food ahead
of the poor New Yorkers a food fight in
one neighborhood in Queens between Nicha
tenants and newly arrived migrants foxes
Ashley Rodriguez shows us how tension
are growing with not enough food to go
around why do we have to take the butt
of everything okay this community here
is already suffering the residents
living in nich's Queensbridge houses
look forward to the mobile food pantries
that show up weekly but over the past
year they have witnessed 8,000 migrants
moving to their neighborhood and they
have also noticed the migrants are also
starting to take their stuff they was
first online for the turkeys this
morning if they tell you to be there at
11 11:00 you get there like 10:30 10:45
but they already out there the line is
from over there to over here free food
giveaways especially during the holidays
have become a source of tension between
longtime New Yorkers struggling to get
by and newly arrived migrants who are
using the system to survive a month ago
one altercation got so heated between a
resident and a migrant someone ended up
in the hospital we would never turn
anyone away for a meal but there simply
just is not enough for both Nitra
residents and the migrant shelter
residents what the left does brilliantly
here is they exploit a little kernel of
Truth to invert the truth it's like it's
the fake news which is they say well in
your charity especially on Thanksgiving
you should of course share with the
stranger and the
Foreigner yeah of course I totally agree
with
that but does that mean that that in
order to fulfill that uh Act of Charity
we should take things away from our
fellow
countrymen that we should deny to the
poor here in
America the food on Thanksgiving so that
we can give it to foreigners who have
exploited our system and broken our laws
I don't that's not what that means that
would that's rather unjust I don't find
that particularly charitable at all yeah
we're going to go into one of the worst
neighborhoods in New York and we're
going to take away food from all you
guys all you poor New Yorkers and we're
going to give it to illegal aliens who
break our
laws many of whom are mobbed up with the
cartel yeah that's what we're going to
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
even if you want to give to the to the
Foreigner it's a it's a violation of
charity for your fellow men because
charity does in fact begin at home and
this is an abundant country there's a
lot to go around
but this is a part of a deeper ideology
that says not only should we not prefer
the familiar to the foreign not only
should we not prefer the near and the
Practical to the abstract and the
universal we should actually only prefer
the abstractions we should only support
the foreigners we should totally deny
any sense of filial piety
patriotism or concern for our community
not a very good message for Thanksgiving
that wouldn't be the message of the
pilgrims no Sur nothing American about
that right now go to goodranchers.com
use promo code nles there's a lot at
stake this November so don't be a
chicken and shop at the grocery store
per usual head on over to good ranchers
where they've got great meat meat that
is even better than my meat puns don't
miss their Black Friday your way sale
now live this November get your favorite
meat free for a year that is one year
free steak salmon chicken or bacon when
you subscribe to any box right now
better yet when you subscribe on
goodranchers.com you not only get a free
gift of meat worth up to 480 bucks you
also get $15 off with code nolles the
only deal your grocery store offers is
on expiring Foods so ditch that meat
aisle subscribe at good ranchers.com
it's the best meet out there the prices
are unbelievably low and then you get
incredible freebies on top of that I
don't know how their finances work but
it's just amazing they these guys are
the best in the business claim your year
of free meat 15 bucks off free shipping
with code NES kwas at goodranchers.com
good ranchers is the number one place to
get all American beef pork chicken and
seafood seafood you ever do that when
you were a kid you like seafood B well
you can do that with good Ranchers go
use promo code nesg goodranchers.com
good ranchers American Meat delivered
right now go to Pac shield.com promo
code nolles Pak shield.com promo code
nles whether you are a parent frequent
traveler simply an individual seeking
enhanced personal safety you got to
check out Pac Shield Pac Shield is a
ballistic insert that fits into
backpacks messenger bags and briefcases
the inserts meet the National Institute
of justice and 3A standards to stop a 44
magnum pack Shield comes in a variety of
sizes and colors so they can be easily
transferred from bag to bag and weigh
less than most textbooks and laptops
when properly packed in your bag this
remarkable insert can provide an extra
layer of protection it is stressful to
think about a situation where you might
need pack Shield but it's worth it to be
ready pack Shield provides extra peace
of mind but it's important to know how
to carry it correctly pack Shield should
never be used for any reason other than
personal defense so pack some protection
and some peace of mind with pack Shield
check them out for yourself at pack
shield.com promo code nlls KW for 20 to%
off that is Pak shield.com promo code
nlls for 20% off today scientists warn
sex toys can cause
diabetes Now if you're listening to this
show you probably you know you're a
wholesome person you're not you probably
don't do too much of this but if you're
if if you're involved in this get rid of
it it will give you diabetes according
to the scientists how is that well
because microplastic
particles from numerous
sources are ingested and absorbed into
the
bloodstream this is true when you drink
a bottle of water this is true as you
just move about our environment which
has some pollution in it but apparently
it's especially true with sex toys which
are far less regulated and which can
include higher uh levels of phalates
which can affect hormone levels and in
present concentrations exceed us
consumer warnings they outline here the
four types of currently available sex
toys that are the worst offenders I'm
not going to read those out because
they're gross and I don't even want to
think about it anymore but this is the
kind of story that I totally
buy because it proves a point that I've
long thought which is one doing weird
sex stuff has negative consequences even
if you can't foresee them and
two doing weird stuff
period all often has negative
consequences even if you can't foresee
it very few people would ever think well
I I'm debating using a sex toy but I
sure don't want to get diabetes someday
you wouldn't even think about it you
wouldn't think that there's any
connection between those things and yet
there can
be well I really want to do this thing
or that thing but I don't want to catch
monkey pox well okay all right that's
that was an issue that a couple years
ago some New Yorkers especially were
dealing with but I I love the the rule
applied even more broadly it's such a
conservative point of view forget the
weird sex stuff for a
second conservatives tend to prefer the
tried to the
untried the familiar to the
unfamiliar in part out of prejudice
because we're not going to write a
20page research paper on every single
question that we have in the day we're
just going to have to go on our gut ins
inct otherwise you wouldn't be able to
get out of bed and when we see that
something has been done everywhere for
all of human history just about
everywhere on Earth certainly every
civilized place on Earth we tend to
believe that's a good behavior and we
ought to consider adopting it or
continuing it when we see that a certain
Behavior or conception has never been
practiced anywhere on Earth ever until
say 5 minutes ago we tend to recoil from
that a great example of this would be
marriage
for all of human history virtually
everywhere on Earth marriage has meant
something and it's involved sexual
difference and
complimentarity about 8 years ago a
romantic poet sitting on the Supreme
Court decided to totally invert that
idea and a lot of people said well what
could go wrong what could go wrong what
could go wrong what could go wrong by
redefining the fundamental political
institution what could go wrong by
inverting the conception of human nature
that we've had everywhere on Earth for
all of human history I don't know I I
can't can't I I do know I could list a
hundred different things that could go
wrong but there there are actually a
thousand there are 2,000 things that
could go wrong you couldn't even predict
that sex toys will give you
diabetes surely you can't predict all of
the unforeseen consequences that come
along with
redefining reordering fundamental
aspects of our
politics man that was a great clip huh
now hey whoa whoa whoa hold up you got
to ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls YouTube channel we'll see
next time